-Today is Friday,
and that's usually
when I catch up on
some personal stuff, you know?
I check my in-box,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
Now, I was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Well, I was running
a bit behind today,
so I thought --
I was busy today.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
I was trying to make all
my money back in scratch-offs.
[ Laughter ]
So, I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd just like the write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now --
is that cool with you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aww.
-You're the best. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
James, can I get some
thank-you-note writing music,
please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-Wow!
-Thank you, New Mexico,
legalizing
recreational marijuana.
Or as stoners put it,
"Wait, there's a New Mexico?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Costco,
for bringing back free samples
to your stores.
Because if the pandemic
has taught me one thing,
it's that I should eat loose
meat from strangers' hands.
-Aww.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Aww! That's sweet.
So sweet.
-Sweet meat.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, the new speakeasy in
New York City's subway station.
Usually,
if I want to see someone
secretly drink alcohol
in the subway system,
I have to ride the subway.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And I don't.
-Secretly.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Red Lobster's
new Codzilla fish sandwich
for sounding
a lot more appetizing
than Arby's
Kongrilla nuggets.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh!
-It sounds like
a male exotic dancer.
[ Laughter ]
"I'll have a sack of nuggets."
-"Coming to the stage...
Codzilla."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Uber CEO,
saying the company
may soon deliver weed.
Or as Papa John's drivers
put it,
"Hey, that's our thing."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ Well, you're too hot to trot,
now, baby ♪
♪♪
♪ Too hot to stop ♪
Whoo!
♪♪
[ Music ends ]
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, new dog park
with a bar opening in Buffalo.
Or as dogs put it,
"Whatever you need on justify
your problem, Glenn."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Whatever you need, bud."
-"Whatever, man."
-Oh, oh.
♪♪
-Thank you, new high-alcohol
White Claw Surge,
for answering the question,
what if LaCroix
made you throw up and cry?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-True.
-Oh.
♪♪
-Thank you, condiments,
for always looking like
you're having a party
on my refrigerator's balcony.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-♪ Too hot to trot ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Mnh!
Well...
[ Laughter ]
That's just --
That's my jam, that song.
-Yeah, that's it.
That's a great song.
♪ Well, you're too hot to trot,
now, baby ♪
-Whoo!
-Unh!
♪ Too hot to stop ♪
-Whoo!
♪♪
-Is it, "Too hot to trot,"
and then...
-"Too hot to stop."
-Yeah.
-'Cause you're trotting.
And then, you're --
you know, you can't stop.
-That's a jam.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
-Is this the last one?
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
-Is that the last
thank-you note?
-Uh. Yeah, sure.
'Cause it looks like it, right?
-Yeah. That's nice, sweet.
-Yeah, it's cool.
-I like it.
-Man.
-I like how you thank people.
I think it's a good attitude.
-Yeah?
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Hold on a second.
[ Light laughter ]
"Unplug Higgins' microphone."
[ Laughter ]
Send.
[ Feedback whines ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wha-- Hey --
I didn't --
[ No audio ]
Ub-- Ah--
[ Laughter ]
Ah -- Ah -- Ah --
-Just turn it back on.
Turn it back on.
-A big bowl of Dick's.
-Oh, okay, alright, alright.
Hey.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, is he talking
about the coupon cards?
-Yeah, the coupon cards
from Dick's Sporting Goods.
-The coupons from
Dick's Sporting Goods.
-Yeah. They're giving them away.
-Yeah, I know, I know.
But then, you couldn't --
we couldn't hear
what you were saying --
the microphone was cutting out.
-Why was the microphone
cutting out?
-I don't know.
I'm sorry.
-It's like a big grab offer --
grab as many Dick's as you can.
-I know. I know. Everyone --
Yeah, I gotcha. Gotcha. Got--
You either got to either put
his mic on or turn it off.
-I love that store.
Love that store.
-You got to mic on
or turn his mic off.
It's one or the other.
Sorry.
-Alright. It's on?
[ Claps twice ]
[ Speaking rhythmically ]
Mic on.
[ Laughter ]
-Mm.
♪♪
-Thank you, hanging plants,
or as I like to call you,
"decorative jellyfish."
They're you go, everybody.
Those are our thank-you notes.